[Music]
welcome
have a seat whatever's going on you can
tell me that's what i'm here for
you're relatively new to the company
i mean i've been working here for nearly
two months and you're under a lot of
stress
entry-level jobs in this industry are
tough right
long hours first one in last one out
goodnight you're smart you have to be
smart it's a tough job
but i can see that you've got what it
takes
i want those new pages before i get on
the planet he promised the first thing
where we are 200k in two points
maybe he can put in a good word for you
no he'll hire externally
listen his schedule has shifted to 7pm
work
still at the hotel or yes
what this is turkey i said chicken
there's a girl waiting oh her she's been
here before a few times
what is it the wife say he's in an
important meeting i'll say he's in the
screening
where is he what did you say they told
me you were smart
i overreacted it was not my place to
question your decision
i will not let you down again you know
you can always come to us right
come to us first okay the last two
checks don't have a name or anything
just a dollar amount uh i can ignore it
okay and will he know what it's for yep
he'll know
i wouldn't sit there never sit on the
couch here
and here initial here sign there do i
need a lawyer or something
do you have a lawyer
i mean they were just like laughing
about it
can you deal with this hi why me
who was that for that waste of my time
your mom and i were excited for you it's
a great opportunity
what can we do do about what
[Music]
you